die science fiction der 80er und 90er
jahre hat sich vor allem mit einer
düsteren zukunft beschäftigt grille
reklametafeln mega firmen und düstere
megacities dahinter steckte vor allem
die angst dass städte enger werden die
luft immer dreckiger und unser leben im
allgemeinen grau und trist die stadt der
zukunft war damals eine
menschenfeindliche umgebung und auch
wenn das heutige lr gott sei dank nicht
so aussieht wie das 2 vl in blade runner
sind manch andere städte gar nicht so
weit davon entfernt aber leben wir
wirklich bald alle in einer cyber punk
megacity ich glaube nicht stattdessen
hoffe ich darauf dass wir uns von der
natur noch so einiges abschauen können
wir haben recherchiert was es alles an
nachhaltigen und lebenswerten trends für
die stadt der zukunft gibt quasi ein
optimistischer gegenentwurf zur blade
runner dystopie herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video bei doktor watson und
abonniert gerne den kanal und kein neues
video zu verpassen
wer schon mal nach einer wohnung in
berlin köln hamburg münchen oder wo auch
immer gesucht hat der weiß der platz ist
immer mehr deutsche ziehen in die
großstadt und wenn wir wachsende städte
und klima ziele unter einen hut bekommen
wollen dann muss sich die versorgung
produktion und das wohnen in der stadt
dauerhaft verändern
wir brauchen eine nachhaltige
umweltfreundlichere statt
wir brauchen eine biobasierte statt im
vergleich zur düsteren megacity stellt
die biobasierte stadt einen kompletten
gegenentwurf da sie wird immer organisch
das heisst von konsum über
abfallentsorgung bis hin zum wohnen und
der landwirtschaft wird alles
umweltfreundlich organisiert okay aber
wie kriegt man das hin
eine möglichkeit die gebäude
interagieren mit der stadt und erwachen
sozusagen zum leben das sie zum beispiel
ist ein konzept für die küste von hong
kong jungle
das soll ein autarker wortwörtliche
großstadtdschungel mitten in hongkong
werden
jedes dieser hochhäuser soll die
pflanzen für eine hohe biodiversität
sorgen
durch eine kombination aus erneuerbaren
energien produzieren die häuser dabei
mehr energie als sie verbrauchen
überschüssige energie kann dann weiter
verwendet werden
ein ähnliches konzept wird von den
architekten hinter anti smog verfolgt
dieses museum soll eine eigene insel auf
der szenen in paris bekommen und alle
formen von erneuerbaren energien
bereitstellen und sogar den pariser smog
bekämpfen
die dächer des museums bieten zum
beispiel 250 quadratmeter platz für
solarmodule
diese sollen mit titandioxid überzogen
werden dieses reagiert damit sonnenlicht
und befreit so die luft vom smog
begrünte fassaden funktionieren hier als
luftfilter und auch frischer zugleich
pflanzen kühlen die im sommer
aufgeheizte stadtluft indem sie bei
hohen temperaturen wasser verdunsten und
gleichzeitig filtern sie gase ruß oder
feinstaub und dem den stadtlärm
zusätzlich bieten sie auch noch wohnraum
für insekten spinnen und vögel
bisher ist das natürlich alles mehr
visionen als realität
trotzdem geben uns solche prototypen
einen vorgeschmack welche visuelle
richtung die stadt der zukunft
einschlagen könnte eine lebenswerte
grüne umgebung bereits jetzt gibt es
aber schon zukunftsweisende biobasierte
wolkenkratzer wie zb der user tower in
bremen da in norwegen
dieser besteht beinahe komplett aus holz
dabei wird 75 prozent weniger co2 im
gegensatz zum bau mit konventionellen
materialien ausgestoßen und das
verrückte ist dieses hochhaus ist sogar
brand sicherer als herkömmliche
hochhäuser das haus besteht nämlich zu
einem großen teil aus unbehandeltem
vollholz und schafft so seine eigene
feier beständige oberfläche da die
äußere schicht bei feuer verkohlt und
damit das holz vor weitere beschädigung
durch feuer gefeit ist deswegen kann der
user tatsächlich zwei stunden lang
lichterloh brennen bisher einstürzt bei
stahl und beton geht das wesentlich
schneller
vielleicht bauen wir in zukunft also
wieder mit holz anstelle von beton
da das extrem viel energie benötigt
übrigens wenn ihr fragen habt dann
stellt sie sehr gerne unten in den
kommentaren auch gerne ausführlichere
fragen denn die kollegen von
wissenschaft im dialog werden die
spannendsten fragen an experten
weiterleiten auf wissenschaft kontrovers
punkt de könnt ihr euch dann die
antworten der experten durchlesen
ein weiterer baustein für die zukunft
ist graphen ein leichtes super starkes
wundermaterial was auch für den
häuserbau in der biobasierten stadt
interessant sein könnte mehr über graf
ihn und seine wirklich unglaublichen
eigenschaften er fest übrigens in diesem
video hier
das stadtbild der metropole 2.0 trägt
maßgeblich zur energieversorgung bei wie
schon bei der partie
lange wird es immer mehr gebäude geben
die nicht nur ihren eigenen
energieverbrauch decken sondern
überschüssige energie in das öffentliche
netz einspeisen nachhaltigen strom gibt
es jetzt schon um grünen strom für die
biobasierte stadt bereit zu stellen gibt
es aber leider keine universallösung
energie durch biomasse photovoltaik
anlagen oder windkraft müssen nämlich
alle hand in hand arbeiten
je nach stadtviertel kann die
energieversorgung also komplett
unterschiedlich aussehen da sich bedarf
und umstände
je nach viertel unterscheiden auch in
der landwirtschaft wird sich einiges
verändern
die lebensmittelversorgung der
biobasierten stadt wird zum beispiel
vielleicht durch vertikale fahnen
bereichert werden
beim vertical farming werden
lebensmittel möglichst platzsparend
übereinander statt nebeneinander
angebaut so dass keine großen
ackerflächen gebraucht werden mit hilfe
von künstlichem licht automatischer
temperatur und licht regulierung werden
hier optimale bedingungen für die
landwirtschaft mitten in der innenstadt
geschaffen
in singapur kann eine farm zb bereits
jetzt jedes jahr 80.000 tonnen obst und
gemüse auch nur 250 quadratmetern
produzieren
zum vergleich mit derselben fläche ak
kann ein bauer je nach gemüse nur ein
bis drei tonnen pro saison produzieren
ein deutsches startup setzt auf
intelligente kräutergärten dafür hat das
unternehmen ein system entwickelt dass
kräuter und gemüse in smarten glas
schränken heranwachsen lässt
auch hier wird die temperatur das licht
und die nährstoffdichte für die pflanzen
so angepasst dass die kräuter optimal
wachsen und dann nur noch geerntet
werden müssen
bisher stehen auch schon über 200 dieser
schränke in supermärkten überall in
deutschland frankreich oder der schweiz
die biobasierte metropole der zukunft
hat aber auch einen verschwindend
geringen plastik verbrauch organische
materialien verpacken dann deine
einkäufe plastik freie alternativen gibt
es natürlich auch jetzt schon wie zum
beispiel biologisch abbaubare strohhalme
aus essbarem material in laboren
arbeiten wissenschaftler aber gerade an
noch vielversprechendere alternativen
wie zum beispiel liegen ihnen das ist
ein in zellulose enthalten des bio
polymer aus nicht essbaren abfällen wie
zum beispiel nussschalen holz oder stroh
aus verarbeitetem linien kann man
klebeband mikrowellen oder auch gummi
so zieren ein ingenieur team der tu
hamburg stellt damit in ihrer dafür
gegründeten firma bereits circa 100 kilo
bio plastik pro jahr her okay das sind
alles megacoolen projekte und konzepte
aber wir können unsere großstädte nicht
von einem tag auf den anderen view
basiert umgestalten vor allem die
mobilität in der biobasierten stadt
braucht aufwendige stadtplanung denn die
innenstädte in der stadt der zukunft
sind hoffentlich autofrei gestaltet und
um den rest der stadt und die umwelt zu
entlasten hat sie ein gut ausgebautes
öffentliches verkehrsnetz bus und bahn
werden nachhaltig hergestellt und
betrieben die hamburger hochbahn nutzt
beispielsweise seit jahren
zertifizierten ökostrom damit so keinen
mobilitäts vakuum entsteht braucht es
durchdachte stadtplanung melbourne in
australien hat zum beispiel ein so
schlau geplantes business führte dass es
dort eine 40-prozentige fußgänger quote
gibt kopenhagen und amsterdam haben ein
netz aus radwegen so dass es fast keinen
sinn ergibt mit dem auto zu fahren da
das tatsächlich viel länger dauert
die städte sind hier mit dem fahrrad im
sinn gebaut worden und nicht mit dem
auto
[Musik]
innovative startups und konzepte gehen
einen weiten weg um uns näher an die
biobasierte stadt der zukunft zu bringen
aber die aufgabe eine nachhaltige welt
zu schaffen kann uns niemand komplett
abnehmen das leben in der stadt der
zukunft wird sich auch für uns verändern
müssen unser konsum gerade ist nur durch
kurzfristig gedachte teilweise
rücksichtslose produktion möglich alles
ist auf kosten und nutzen ausgelegt aber
nicht auf nachhaltigkeit und voraussicht
positive auswirkungen auf die umwelt und
den menschen lassen sich leider nicht an
der börse handeln
und dann ist da noch die frage der
verfügbarkeit und kosten hübsche
nachhaltige wolkenkratzer kosten geld
wir müssen also auch darüber nachdenken
wie verhindert werden kann dass die
biobasierte stadt ein elitäres zentrum
für die oberen paar prozent wird wenn
nachhaltiges und lebenswertes wohnen in
der grünen utopie nur eine handvoll
menschen ermöglicht wird dann spaltet
sich die gesellschaft und kluften
zwischen ärmeren produktionsländern und
den profitierenden ländern wachsen
natürlich handelt es sich bei der
biobasierten stadt um eine stückweise
transformation unserer großstädte
wahrscheinlich wirst du nicht eines
morgens in einer grünen hightech utopie
aufwachen wirtschaftliche trends und zum
beispiel auch die ziele der
bundesregierung geben uns aber schon mal
eine grobe richtung vor in die es gehen
könnte
und ich finde da lohnt es sich
optimistisch zu bleiben was die zukunft
für uns aber wirklich bereit hält das
kann niemand wissen und warum ganz schön
schlau und berühmte leute mit ihren
zukunftsvisionen auch schon falsch lagen
darum geht es in diesem video hier das
hier war der zweite teil unserer reihe
über das wissenschaftsjahr 2020
bioökonomie den ersten teil findest du
hier unten und ansonsten vielen dank an
die gemeinnützige organisation
wissenschaft im dialog und an das
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung für die unterstützung bei
diesem video
bis dahin bleibt neugierig patrick